I know I thank you for putting on a
brave face because really this is a
rough week in the news we had a horrible
mass shooting today there were planes
falling out of the sky Venezuela
this is on the brink of utter chaos so
let's get right to the big story and
Becky from Full House might go to jail
for cheating her kids into college and
you know this is the College Admission
scandal everybody is talking about I
have shocking news for everyone here
tonight rich people cheat and their kids
are [ __ ] stupid if you haven't heard
about all this now federal prosecutors
on Wednesday charged 50 people in this
massive you heard that right
okay just sometimes I don't know the pot
you know never before this show anyone
always after anyway but 50 people have
been charged in this massive scheme to
bribe coaches and administration
officials to their kids could get into
elite colleges and the schools involved
we're talking about Yale Stanford
Georgetown some of the most prestigious
[ __ ] factories in America
and come on this candle has been very
tough on the Hollywood community well
really the face of it is two actresses
Lori Loughlin that's Aunt Becky and
Felicity Huffman Huffman who they said
on Wednesday woke up to guns drawn they
woke her up in her house nobody wants to
see a gun before they've had their
coffee and I thought celebrities would
know better you know if your kids too
stupid to get into college you don't
bribe and cheat you put them in
Scientology some of the athletic
programs they were faking their kids
into water polo the crew Team Tennis
sailing you know the street sports this
is not affirmative action for white
people I don't know you might as well
admit students for bad dancing and
parking at Trader Joe's I don't know but
yeah they would bribe these coaches and
make their kids sometimes with
photoshopping look like star athletes
let me tell you something my parents
wouldn't do this that generation would
not have spent their hard-earned dollars
trying to make their kids look
interesting they would straight-up tell
you you're you're pretty boring you're
gonna go to Community College Lori
Loughlin daughter who got into USC a
double major of Red Bull and vodka yes
here's the galling part this kid doesn't
even want to go to college she said so a
million times doesn't even want to go to
college and it interfered with a career
of taking selfies in the bathroom she's
she's she's what they call an Instagram
influencer and a YouTube blue beauty you
say it three times a YouTube beauty
blogger a YouTube blurted a YouTube
beauty blogger anyway but now with the
scandal she hasn't been online in in
days in fact when I was getting off the
freeway today I think I saw her by the
overpass
she had a sign that said will offer
lipglass tips for food I couldn't get
that one out either all right
they dug up some of some of her Olivia
Jade is the name she goes by some of her
old quotes like I don't know how much
I'm going to attend this school but I
got into that's what you don't really
care about my studies it's so hard to
try but you don't care about what you're
learning Wow
this kid is too dumb for the football
players she she got into USC she thought
their mascot was a condom those of you
who not in California it's the Trojans
is they that's the joke that we're the
USC for but all right enough of that in
our latest installment of this weekend
dictatorship this is really chilly you
know I've been on this theme for a very
long time the president the other day
said the worst thing ever he said I had
the support he's basically threatening
us he said I have the support of the
police I have the support of the
military I have the support of bikers so
even there yes the hell's that gonna be
Altamont for the whole country the Hells
Angels are gonna get involved he said I
have the tough people he talked about
how until they're gonna be okay until
they meaning us liberals go to a certain
point and then it's gonna be very very
bad well he hasn't counted on one thing
liberals we have this abortive NPR and
the vegans and academia
yeah that's a joke we're [ __ ] okay
that's the joke they have the guns and
we have the Millennials in their pajamas
for Christ's sake
I'm more scared than ever but you know
we have a new candidate Beto got in the
race better I work from Texas now
there's 15 candidates Trump is already
calling them a caravan I mean somebody
options that's pretty I feel like a
stoner looking at the menu board at Taco
Bell I mean there's just so much to
choose from but you know I must say Beto
his moves pretty popular a while ago and
now it's all been greeted with a white
guy suddenly the I don't see color
people see color
you know white black who cares let's
stop Orange
and come on think of the matchup Beto
and Trump oh my god Instagram versus
telegram iPhone versus payphone not some
interesting parallels between Trump and
Beto as a teenager this is true
Beto a belong to a computer hacking
group called the cult of the dead cow
and as an adult
Trump belongs to a computer hacking
group called Russia
you